Josh follows us on Facebook I have three
credit cards but I'm ready to tackle
this debt should I concentrate on paying
off the highest interest rate or should
I divide up between the three well the
first thing I want you to do Josh is
save $1,000 as your starter beginner
emergency fund and then I want you to
list all of your debts not counting your
home from smallest debt to largest debt
regardless of the interest rate pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one and attack the little one
with the vengeance ah when you knock out
the little one then you attack the next
one when you knock out the next one you
knock out the next one so if you're only
dead are these three credit cards I
don't care what the interest rates are
you list them smallest to largest and I
want you to completely focus on that
smallest one like it's the enemy of your
soul won't you go after it like a tiger
man and you knock out that smallest one
when it's gone you knock out the next
one all day wouldn't we pay off the
highest interest rate first that'd be
mathematically correct well if we were
doing math people we wouldn't have
credit card debt this is not a math
problem this is a behavior problem and
you fix a behavior problem with a
behavior based solution and so for 20
years we've taught people to pay off the
smallest to largest and we've taught
more people how to get out of debt than
anyone else anywhere four million people
have been through Financial Peace
University now 10 million people listen
to this radio show five million people
have bought the book the Total Money
Makeover we've taught more people how to
get out of debt than anyone else it's
that simple
and this works so you know and it still
just tickles the crud out of me I had a
tweet this morning somebody was a click
baiting us and Dave Ramsey's wrong he
says you know his math is wrong you
should pay off the highest interest rate
first if Dave Ramsey was wrong he'd been
on a business a long time ago doofus the
reason we do so well is because this
stuff freakin works it's that simple
Dave Ramsey's not wrong not on this I
might be wrong about something else you
might find that out from my wife I'm
probably wrong about something but I am
NOT wrong about this when you pay off
that smallest debt you get the
check that box and go boom I just lost
some weight I'm on a diet
boom I'm going to keep going this is
encouraging I like the way this feels
I'm winning I'm making progress for the
first time in my freakin life I've got
traction on this money stuff that's how
you start to feel so the answer is you
list them smallest to largest and you
pay minimum payments on everything but
the little one and you attack the little
one with a vengeance listen you can
wander your butt into debt you cannot
wander your butt out of debt no one
accidentally wins the Super Bowl how'd
that happen
that never comes out of an athlete's
mouth when they finish winning the Super
Bowl you don't accidentally win the
World Series
you will not accidentally get out of
debt you'll never look up go where'd all
that go it just disappeared you know you
know but you will look up and go where'd
that come from you just wander along the
mall and strike here strike there strike
here and it's death by a thousand cuts
and you look up and you have no freaking
money and you're deeply in debt you
can't breathe
stupid has a gravitational pull and the
only way you break the orbit is stupid
and break that kind of gravitational
pull is you have to get fired up and you
have to get passionate and you have to
get crazy if you're broke friends are
not making fun of your financial plan
you don't have the right plan you have
to get crazy you have to get nuts you
have to run like your very life depends
on it that's how you get out of debt
well you sound like you're kind of like
you know it's like I'm some kind of a
preacher or something well maybe maybe
this is an exorcism you know maybe the
devil made you do it I don't know but
you need to get up off your butt and go
do something different and that's what
changes things folks I'm not talking to
you Josh on Facebook I'm just saying in
general the way you get out of debt is
you have to get fired up and wired up
the great motivator Les Brown says
people only change their lives when they
finally say I've had
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired when you get there you'll change
your life you don't have to be broke you
just have to reach a moment where you
say I've had it you don't have to go
bankrupt I want a bankrupt coz I'm too
stupid to figure it out otherwise I'd
lose everything the only way God got my
attention I'm so thick you had to head
to hit me in the face with the two
before I'm laying on my back looking up
wondering what hit me lost everything
had to start over you don't have to be
that stupid you can make a decision
today to go I worked too hard I make too
much money to be this freakin broke I've
had it I'm changing my life
you can decide today you could just
decide it's a free country so far so far
there's not a communist running the
place sorta you just got to decide
decide right now right now you I'm
talking to you you decide right now I'm
going to change my life thing just like
that you started the process then you
have to put new information in your
brain and let me just tell you he'd turn
off your stupid television some of you
people know more about Donald Trump's
retirement plan than you know about your
own now that's dumb some of you people
can tell me more about the the 7300
Republican candidates then you can tell
me about your income and your career you
know the average millionaire doesn't do
this crap average millionaire can't tell
you who got thrown off the island
they'll spend all their time getting
sucked into stupidity on television and
I'm not saying televisions devil I'm
just saying most of stuff on there is
crap and you're wasting your time
putting crap in your brain and wondering
why your life's full of crap well duh
you need to think differently today's
the day I'm going to change my life
today is my day today today I've had it
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired I'm not living like this anymore I
work too hard to be this broke I work
too hard too
this mess every day in the face and go I
can't get ahead I sure hope they came to
president I hope we get a different
present hope we change everything
because one of them those people we said
in Washington is going to fix my life
let me tell you Donald Trump is not
sending you anything Barack Obama didn't
send you a check and Donald Trump and
I'll send you a check you're not getting
a check from them they're broke
Washington's broke and they can't add
hadn't you noticed so don't sit around
and wait on someone else to fix your
life this is America the greatest
country the world has ever known
get up off your butt and go fix your
life starting today I'm gonna change my
life today
today I'm going to take a class I'm
going to read a nonfiction book I'm
going to sit down and do a budget on
every dollar tonight for free I'm going
to start a discussion with my spouse
because I don't want to retire and hope
social insecurity will take care of me I
don't want to work my whole life and my
whole retirement plan my golden years
are based on the government's ability to
handle money well that's dumb you know
they're stupid
so if your only plan is to count on them
and that makes you stupid
don't be stupid it's painful change your
life make a decision I'm going to change
my life starting today Dean just like
that thing I hate my job what there's
something about it what you think
there's a job fairy nobody's going to
fly in here and fix your job either
start being a better team member get to
reading grow your butt up or get your
tail out of there I hate my boss well he
feeds your family you probably need a
new boss or maybe you need a new
attitude you need to get up off your
butt and change your life today is your
day ding I changed my life I began the
process today and then a wonderful thing
this thing we have called freedom you're
not trapped
the only thing trapped is between your
freaking ears get up off your butt leave
the cave kill something and drag it home
you're not trapped you're not a victim
the economy's not stacked against you
it's not Walmart's fault it's your fault
fix it this is the Dave Ramsey show